depuis dieu plus un certain temps il ya
tout l'eau du lycée schoelcher qui coule
en dessous de ma maison
alors ce qu'il fait ils ont fait ça ça
toi et tes est fissurée et l'ol passe
dans les fissures alors ça colle comme
une rivière ce chantier de construction
du nouveau lycée schoelcher un pointé du
doigt par bon nombre de riverains du
quartier font populaire un quartier
situé non loin de bonal
à fort-de-france et des conseils mais
c'est quoi ces travaux allaient
s'échanger les nouveaux lycéens
eh bien nous quand j'ai trouvé qu'on est
ici il ya autour de bouées puis loca
pass et tous partout et à les garder
ces clubs là l'avocat arrivé il ya
beaucoup de boue d'autres personnes
avancent que leurs nuits sont plutôt
coûte à cause de fortes précipitations
dans le secteur quand il pleut en notant
qu'au bruit et puis quand on regarde on
regarde on a l'impression que c'est une
lisière nous nous la rivière quoi et il
semblerait qu'une bulle souterraines a
obstrué soit à l'origine de ce désordre
la musicalité foyalaise confiance ces
allégations des recherches la ville
intervenu pendant 48 heures et on a
constaté effectivement ce sont les
travaux du lycée chercheurs quitterai
cette innovation certaines habitations
construites dans les années 50 sont
doublement fragile et c'est par ces
inondations à répétition sans de france
et construit une serre quartier et hexa
courbe o'conner populaires se sont
construits de l'habitat spontané
aujourd'hui il est ancien moderniser et
nous travaillons avec la chose et 50 pas
pour faire des propositions à la
population le porte parole du conseil
exécutif d'ing cité m daniel barry 7
refuse le moment de s'exprimer devant
notre caméra
il précise tout de même que les
consignes ont été données afin de
déterminer les causes exactes de cette
inondation
si elles relèvent de la compétence de la
ctm des travaux sont rapidement réalisé
en revanche si ce dérangement provient
du réseau d'eaux pluviales les
responsabilités seraient de la
compétence de la mairie de
fort-de-france